I've learned something new recently I
want to share it with you to recreate
something that was in one of my previous
videos which is about proof by
contradiction of our proof by
contradiction is one of the coolest ways
of proving things that there is there's
proof by deduction and induction proof
by contradiction is one of the most
clever ways that there is to show that
something is true okay and we don't tend
to use it all that much in high school
maths which is a shame I guess and part
of that is because it's quite confusing
now here's the way it works suppose you
want to prove this statement if P is
true then Q is true okay now we come up
with these kinds of statements all the
time in maths and so we usually would
look at the given information what you
know about P what you know about Q and
sort of progress linearly naturally from
P to Q okay and that's the way that most
of us have learnt to prove things okay
and the way of proof by contradiction
works is to assume that this the premise
what you're trying to prove you assume
that it's false you see in the opposite
and then you work with that assumption
and then you've shown that there's some
contradiction that results from the
assumption you made and so if there's
some contradiction that means your prior
assumption of the beginning must have
been wrong and that means that this your
real statement must be right okay now
when you think about how do I assume the
opposite of this a natural way to think
about it would be this if P is true then
Q is false or Q is not true now that
looks like it's the opposite which is
which is what I've said before and since
no it's not that's not the best way to
say it
the real opposite of this statement up
here is not this but P is true and Q is
false
okay now you're like that looks really
really similar to me and they are very
similar the difference is just one word
in a sense here I have and and here I
have then okay now if you want to go and
have a look and study
the difference between their logic
implications between the differences
there then go ahead and do that but the
point is that there is a difference okay
now to illustrate how that actually
works I'm going to show you a really
cool proof which I have over here and I
really like it because it's in some ways
it's surprising it's quite elegant when
you do it as a proof by contradiction
and also mix together quite a few
different plots of maths okay so tell
look at it now if two different numbers
are positive and real then their
arithmetic mean is larger than their
geometric mean what are all of those
before I explain all of it let me just
point out to you that what you've got is
these two terms which probably the most
natural way that they connect to say to
your maths is I'm series and sequences
you might recognize a minute and
geometric from there okay then you also
have this is large and so you also bring
in the three in a topic of inequalities
okay and so we're going to bring
together these kinds of branches of
maths and prove them prove the statement
by contradiction okay now this is all
wording okay so how do I am and I take
this and put it into mathematical
language well first I have a condition
right so this is my if P is true
he's what I'm gonna call pain right two
different numbers I'm positive and real
okay so I'm gonna say a couple of things
there firstly let's let's give these
numbers names
so let's called on the x and y okay so x
and y solve the real number set and a
positive okay the set of positive real
numbers okay that's this part by default
and the numbers are different they're
two different numbers
okay so X does not equal Y okay so given
that condition I want to prove now why
is this stuff and that it mean geometric
mean the whole idea is very easy to
consider if I give you an example okay
so consider two numbers two and eight
okay now watch you imagine
that there's some third number in
between two and eight okay and when I
put them together I'm going to get a
sequence a series of numbers okay now
depending on what number you put in here
you'll call it a different kind of
series for instance if I want to put the
number five in here okay two five eight
the kind of sequence I have you the kind
of progression is an arithmetic
progression because there's a a common
difference between the terms okay you
add three each time so we would call
this in AP an arithmetic progression
okay now what that means is we call five
the arithmetic mean of two and eight
it's the number you stick between two
and eight to create an arithmetic
progression okay now you can go ahead
and do the maths for this and you can
think about what the terms the
individual terms of an AP huh but
suffice to say that the way you get five
is by taking the average that's another
way of saying mean right off to an eight
so you're gonna add them so you plus a
and then you divide by 2 which gives you
the five that you expect okay so if i
I've got not to an eight but x and y
then are the way to take the average the
arithmetic mean of those is to add them
and then divide by two
that'll give me the arithmetic mean
right now I want to say that the
arithmetic mean is a large in there okay
what's the geometric mean you might be
you know working out what's going on
here if I take the same two numbers two
and eight and I want to imagine another
number in here but instead of making an
AP in arithmetic progression I'll make a
GP a geometric progression well the
number that's going to make this
particular set of three numbers are GP
or before okay because then instead of
going a common difference plus three
plus three I've got a common ratio times
two times two
okay now how did I get four where did
that come from
apart from me just thinking of that
okay or if you take the product of these
two numbers two times eight
right and then you take the square root
that's the square root of 16 which is 4
right so 4 is the geometric mean of 2
and 8 it's the number you stick in
between 2 and 8 and you'll get a GP okay
so instead of 2 & 8 if I have X is y I'm
gonna have the square root of x 1 okay
that's here okay so this is what I'm
setting out to prove okay if I've got
this condition then I want to prove this
inequality okay so now that you know
which one we haven't made you metric
mean how does it prove by contradiction
make this happen okay it's super clever
what you do is you assume the opposite
of this statement you see in the officer
okay now just establish before that the
exact opposite of this is x and y are
real numbers and they're different okay
there's one hut and now I'm gonna assume
that the opposite of this is okay so all
I have to do to make the option that is
turn the inequality around and had the
boundary so I would say this X plus y on
2 is less than or equal to the square
root of XY
okay so acquainting this back to the
form this is P is true and Q is false
because that's what Q is really saying
okay and this is the opposite right okay
well how am I gonna do this I'm gonna go
about doing this I'm gonna start from
over here start from this side okay I'm
going to notice that missing equality
okay because x and y are both real
numbers okay therefore the left hand
side x plus y on to okay
that's going to be greater than zero
okay it's also going to be a positive
alone and in the same way the square
root of XY by definition
also greater than zero okay and I only
know that these are true because they're
both positive numbers okay now since
they're both positive numbers for this
inequality I can square both sides and
it'll work
you know the inequality sign won't turn
around and I won't get different cases
because I know they're both positive
both sides are positive okay just like
if I said to you you know 3 is less than
or equal 5 they're both positive so I
can square both sides and it's still
true the line is still less than or
equal to 25 okay where is if one of them
is negative you might be in trouble okay
right so having established that I'm
going to square both sides right I'll
get this X plus y onto all squared
square root of x square ok so far so
good
we've been at algebra to this if we can
simplify it out a little bit if I square
the top there I'm going to get x squared
plus 2xy plus y squared all over 4 you
go to spray the top and the bottom over
here naturally you just get X Y okay
I'll multiply that 4 across and now I've
got X Y's in common on both sides I'll
collect like terms
excuse me yes okay now that there that's
a perfect square how do you factorize it
it's X minus y or square it's less than
or equal to zero okay and that's about
as simple as it gets I can't really go
any further than that and this follows
directly from this statement which I'm
assuming to be true okay
so therefore I'm going to say sure I'm
going to go with that I'm going to call
that statement 1 okay but that's what I
got from this I can get information from
here too okay think about this x and y
are not the same so I could subtract Y
from both sides and get the difference
between x and y cannot be 0 right
because they're not the same number
right and you see why I might do this
the reason why this is a useful thing to
get is because I have an X minus y here
right okay now hold on I have assumed
that they're both real numbers right one
of the things about the real numbers is
when you square them you'll get
something positive if they're not real I
think complex numbers you've got no
guarantees you might square it and get
something negative but these are real
numbers right so if I square both sides
or square that number really remember
it's not equal to 0 so this thing it's a
square number it's got to be positive it
must be right no matter what values you
stick in for x and y so what is their
positive real numbers if you subtract
one of these square it you'll get
something positive
ok now I'll call this statement two but
hold on statement 1 and
statement 2 directly contradictory they
directly contradict each other so
therefore I can say look I came from
this assumption that this was true but
when I followed that through and thought
about it it ends up in something which
doesn't make sense ok
so therefore this cannot be true this
cannot be true so the opposite of that
is this is this inequality okay so I can
say therefore if they are positive real
numbers that are different then the
opposite of this must be true in other
words the inequality must go the other
way
namely the way that it was facing what
we started okay so that's how you
approach a proof by contradiction